shout out to your lady you're in a nice
uh a nice romance
she uh is the new Little Mermaid yeah
which is incredible
I can't wait to see it
um first of all how dope is that just
like that [ __ ] is historical yeah it's
amazing you know it's beautiful to see
she's been talking about that for a
minute so I'm just really excited for
yeah is she letting any of this [ __ ]
hate get to her
no no
no no no she she's laughing it off it's
kind of crazy maybe they'd be they'd be
going a little too hard but I feel like
the people was more attacking
the character rather than her personally
you know what I'm saying Eve I feel like
it's like caught in a crossfire because
she's playing the character right but I
don't think [ __ ] is like
because any like you it's impossible to
be impossible to be mean to Hallie you
know what I'm saying she seems like the
sweetest girl she's too sweet and she
really like that in person so it's like
it's if people actually took the time to
realize who's actually playing a Little
Mermaid instead of just going off that
she's black I think it they'd be like
every once in a while we get reminded
like how terribly racist America still
is yeah I didn't know if people was This
Racist I didn't know I didn't know this
was neither did I dude I thought this
[ __ ] was gone already I thought that
[ __ ] was gone I thought Martin Luther
King canceled that [ __ ] out it's crazy
this [ __ ] is crazy and I was like what
the [ __ ] is these [ __ ] talking about
oh my God it's bad man well at the end
of the day also it's like it's the
[ __ ] is tapping in they still
gonna watch that [ __ ] oh it's like yeah
it's like thanks for the promotion
that's what I'm gonna say there's no way
that movie comes out is it number one in
the box office I'm saying it's going
number one regardless and every single
black person in the world is gonna watch
that [ __ ] for sure for 100 every little
girl gonna have to buy a [ __ ]
movie ticket for that [ __ ] it's gonna
be babies in that [ __ ] everybody
from [ __ ] zero years old to
75. they all watching that [ __ ] I think
it's been dope to see like the reaction
to like some of the little girls
watching and being like oh she looks
like me like that shit's crazy like
it's like some real inspirational [ __ ]
really changing the world man